let's have a look at the obvious part
okay cos theta square root of 1 minus
cos square theta what are the obvious
things that jump out at you that we can
simplify you can do cos on site over
there at the front what's happening
underneath the square root
good so this is this is one of the
versions of the Pythagorean identity
right since we know that sine squared
plus cos squared equals 1 right
you can kick either of these guys over
the other side in this case they've
taken over cos squared right
so 1 minus cos squared will just leave
you with sine squared right so this is
what you've got now you'll see oh I'm
taking the square root of a square right
so most of you will jump in and just say
it well clearly the square root of a
square is just going to be whatever you
are whatever you had there right but yes
now here's the thing right and in the
middle of a whole bunch of you know
other trig stuff maybe you didn't spot
this but the square root of a square
number right the square of a square
number it's easy it's easy when you're
dealing with positive things
okay the square root of the square of 5
is 5 okay but the square root of the
square minus 5 is not minus 5 because
you square it and you lose the negative
then you take the square root and the
negative doesn't magically come back
both of those are equal to 5 okay so
what this is really saying is that and
if you think back to when we introduced
absolute value ok the square root of a
square is in fact the absolute value of
that squaring like I said it strips out
the fact that it was negative and you
lose that information ok so really
what's going on here is this ok well
then that that there lays the question
well how do I do some canceling business
here ok how would I go about thinking
about this let's think about forget
about it being signed for a second let's
just think you had a simpler example if
it was not trigonometric but if it was
just like this the absolute value of x
over on
X okay now remember the absolute that a
VAX is actually in disguise it's a
piecemeal function right
it's a piecemeal function what's it
actually equal to that absolute value of
X its equal to plus X sometimes and it's
equal to minus X other times so it'll be
x over X sometimes and it will be minus
X over X other times when is it just
equal to plus x squared 0 right and by
contrast when it's less than 0 right and
obviously you can put the UM you can put
the Equality whichever one you like at 0
okay so therefore this function would be
equal to 1 in this domain and it would
be equal to minus 1 an estimate so what
is the graph of this look like we've
done these peaceful functions before
right okay
I'll do the part that's obvious and that
as for where the filled circle would go
oh I know in a full circle we go can't
you see what we see with a filled circle
it's gonna be open on both of them
y-yeah good because I've been given it
as a denominator it's on it's on the
denominator sake I can't ever put it in
okay so I've got I've got two hollow
circles there's the graph okay now just
take what you've seen of this and bring
it now over here okay let's just write
this in a bit of a clearer way slightly
I hope you've got this absolute value
over itself okay
now because it's trig this now makes it
a bit trickier okay because this is
obvious where to take what X and what
it's equal to minus X is it's pretty
clearly defined right now this is also
clearly defined we're not you said the
key in these terms are we when is when
is sine X positive yeah
okay zero to 180 in there positive data
goes negative but because periodic of
course it comes back doesn't it right
this would be 360 up to five the other
way right so this is getting towards
general solution to look at later okay
but the whole point is the whole point
is sometimes side is positive namely in
in these spots okay and other times it's
negative yes yes so I I just figured
this is just sine theta okay so I'm just
trying to work out where it's positive
words they you so I can get my cases and
then I work about my boundary points
later on so really what's happening here
is you're gonna get closed data times
one just like just like this okay when
sine theta is plus is positive right and
that is why I've written the first case
from naught to 180 and then you get a
friend 360 or 450 and on a 540 and on oh
yeah yes yeah yeah which is which is why
I put in this yep it should be this not
that I mean this this capture is all of
them really okay um or alternatively
right it's equal to negative cos theta
when so just quickly before we leave off
this what is this just for sake of
curiosity because why not what is this
thing actually going to look like it's a
piece your function let's have a go
we'll just do it for positive values
okay so for not to 180 that's the first
spot okay you're gonna get cos theta
what is cos theta look like from naught
to 180 you're good you get it starts at
the top
and it comes down to the bottom but
you've only gone halfway so it doesn't
get to come back it doesn't complete the
cycle yeah okay
now yeah yeah I've got got
yeah I think they're awful oh well
double-check that intake yeah now what
happens when I cross over from 180 to
360 we're gonna get minus coz-theta
right now this is what normal cos theta
looks like right so minus cos theta
we'll flip it upside down right so this
guy would come up to here in fact I'm
going to get the same thing again okay
of course it's still periodic all my
pieces are periodic it's just a
different kind of community and in fact
you're gonna get the same shape because
sine theta sine theta is equal to 0 at 0
and it's equal to 0 180 minutes equals 0
here and it's all the denominator no
actually oh yeah it is it goes back to
your first line right you've got a sine
theta on the denominator in your first
line so therefore there must be poly
cycles all right
it's squares square and so not only that
though think about cos theta what's the
range of cos theta yeah that's right
minus one to one okay so therefore no no
stay with me stay with me if the range
of this thing is minus one to one then
when you square it what happens to its
range something does happen it becomes
zero to one actually positive right so
therefore this will always be between
zero and one and all of those are okay
does that make sense this thing will
never ever ever be less than correct